alors Simon comment ça marche voilà une
fois le mort revenu à la vie on peut lui
poser 5 questions après quoi il remerme
de manière définitive pourquoi 5
questions j'en sais rien c'est comme ça
c'est pas arbitraire on peut s'y mettre
s'il vous plaît oui
[Musique]
je prononce mal peut-être
j'ai pas eu peur il m'a juste surpris
à nous deux
à la bataille des Landes éternelles
super pour nous je veux dire et un peu
moins pour toi mes condoléances encore
quatre questions c'est ça non non
s'il te plaît
tu ne réponds que quand je t'interroge
ok pourquoi tu as dit ok à la fin de ta
phrase j'ai pas dit OK
où elle appelle
c'est la plus grande force maléfique
que le monde est connu
on doit réunir une équipe
[Musique]
maintenant comment on fait
on en discute autour d'un verre